what up adorondo
listen up
Squad game maybe uh Vivid
can we just get you guys
[Applause]
oh
let's go
[Music]
welcome auditioners you guys are so
talented so unbelievable this will break
you
this will fully destroy you
congratulations on being the most
talented kids at campus
stoppage jiggle like a chapel a jiggle
like a jackal these are the things we
can do with masks
[Music]
oh I'm sorry sex marker thank you
sad news I will not be doing piercings
anymore in the Hut because there's an
arc amongst us
um Cassie has narked
it's totally fine we're gonna need to
prioritize the musicals which means the
straight plays are gonna have to be
acoustic quick question what's a
straight play there are musicals and
then there are a straight place so then
what would be a gay play
good
[Music]
we only have three weeks to create a
masterpiece it's on you now all on you
let's do this and cue cocaine
[Music]
you need to know that only three percent
of people make it
the rest end up in a mental facility or
on a go-go box in Hell's Kitchen
This Disaster everything is gonna be
okay
we're theater people we know how to turn
cardboard into gold
[Music]
one it's art
minor housekeeping issue whoever stole
my CBD gummies please return that I'm
pretty sure I know who it was